Bầu trở nước bản mong nghe ăn bị chậm diễn độ, cây lặng vĩ
khởi tổ tám bị cá lên quan
dứa ăn hầu trở nước bản mong nghe ăn
sau bong cười lý đầu tư và sây dịch thuy lợi bốn
bản môn, tụi bộn đồng nghiệp và phát triển đúng tôn
đang chủ đấu tư để phơi dịch là mai ngàn không trong lĩnh chính
sự kiến bản đầu, hành thánh năm ngàn không trong mùi làm
tây yên, đến nay đã mùi làm năng chứ qua
dứa ăn vật còn gần nhan, chứ thể về định
các quan cạnh giết đều tra bộ công an
cuộc cạnh rất đề tra tội phạm về thăm những kinh tế
bộn lậu, rất liệt, sửa dịch, sửa ăn
hồi chứ nước bản mong bị chậm giết độ, phải đều
chỉ tổ mức đầu tư nhiều lần, kê lặng vĩ lướng trong năng
sách cả nước, là giáo các sai phạm trong cã chính đấu tư,
thực hiện tương tên từ bộ công an, các quan chích năng đã tế
hành khởi tổ tám bị cán cho bộ an đi sự
lên quan đến sự ăn này, li càng oễn văn dân dân,
sám đất công việc chách nhiệm bố hạn, một tâm viên
đều tư và sê tự hằng dân, li khởi tổ vi tổ vi tổ vi tổ vi tổ
vi tổ quy định về kế tóan, kế hổ quảng nghiêm chọng,
tổ tổ vi tổ quy định về đều thậu, kế hổ quảng nghiêm chọng,
cùng tựa sang về nghiêm phụ kế tóan còn có bà bị càng đi kế tổ,
bầu gồm, phổ thích kinh lên, kế tán chừng công tý hằng dân,
môi tông yên, kế tổ anh công tý hằng dân, mến văn sách, mến sách đất
công tý sà vang, mến kinh đó, một lật đối trực vi khởi tổ
vi sạch quy định về đều thậu, kế hổ quảng nghiêm chọng, bầu gồm, bố định tình,
phó giám tốc công tý hằng dân, phà bà bị càng về là cãn bộ tại bản bốn,
bộ nung nghiệp và phát triển đúng tôn, mấy tình đảnh những chiếc phụ káo nhất
kế còn công tắc là ông thoms sân tình, mến phó giám đất bản bốn,
mấy ra, còn có mến vinh hằng, chừng phong kế hệ thăm định,
sân chỉ thành cãn bộ phụ kảnh lihi thi công, cơ quan cạnh sách đều tra bộ công an
đăng tập trung lực lực lực mở giống như cha làm só hình vì có cắt bị càng lên quan tại công tý hằng dân,
cắt nhạc thậu, đên vị thí công, có cơ quan cạnh lihi nhả nước,
để sử li theo quý định, khô hỏi chế tảy ra.